[Musique]
la couche de glace est une association
créée en décembre 2020 on a ouverte le
10 décembre de mémoire qui a pour
objectif la création de couverture par
des bénévoles de la france entière de
toute petite couverture adaptée aux
enfants nés sans vie suite à des
complications de grossesse à des mort
foetale ou à d ing pour accompagner les
parents
l'été dernier on a perdu lola d'une
complication grossesse et
de fil en aiguille avec le chemin qu'on
a parcouru sur les quelques mois qui ont
suivi on a eu le souhait de créer ça
pour accompagner les parents parce que
nous n'avons pas eu cette chance là à
l'hôpital où on a été suivi on aurait
peut-être été un peu plus loin dans le
chemin de l'accompagner de l'avoir ou
voilà d'avoir un petit moment un peu
plus personnelles sur facebook du coup
la page a été ouverte est en fait en
quelques jours grâce à la une amie de la
famille de mon conjoint qui avait un
groupe de couture et de tricot
on s'est retrouvés où j'ai une soirée où
j'ai pas arrêté d'accepter du monde mais
aussi très vite arriver à une centaine
de personnes là on a dépassé les 300
alors les couvertures sont de petite
taille
on est au niveau de taille entre 40 et
50 cm pour la laine forcément douce
souple et de couleurs douces et neutre
c'est pas que dans le 78 lala le dernier
don a été fait dans le 28
on a réussi dans le sud de la france
dans le xiii principalement
donc non ça on a d'autres régions des
personnes qui sont motivés pour nous
aider aussi d'ailleurs parce qu'il n'ya
pas que chez nous que ça arrive
[Musique]